joe biden qui est donc parti en en
pologne tout à l'heure et qui était
arrivé sur place et qui entre en train
de s'exprimer devant des militaires
américains on écoute le président
américain
passer plus de temps avec moi qu'avec
n'importe quel autre dirigeant du monde
des hommes et il lui pensait que les
démocraties pouvait pas réussir 21e
siècle puisque les changements se
produisent très vite alors que
démocratie ont besoin d'un consensus et
nous on n'y arrive pas aussi rapidement
les autocrates alors l'enjeu c'est pas
uniquement l'ukraine bien sûr il faut
aider les ukrainiens et l'arrêter ce
massacre au delà
à quoi ressembleront vos enfants vos
petits enfants quelle liberté auront-ils
même furieusement que
moins de démocratie de former que de
perdus dans le monde
il s'agit bien plus de savoir si vous
pouvez alléger les souffrances du peuple
ukrainien le dom entrons dans une
nouvelle phase un point de bascule
tous les cinq générations y ait des
changements fondamentaux
le monde ne sera plus le même depuis
10 15 ans dans le structure
organisationnelle et qui va gagner
en démocratie les valeurs que nous
partageons ou bien les autocraties
webster c'est ça quand je donc ce que
vous faites a énormément de conséquences
roppenheim j'ai dit au groupe en salle à
manger
la vérité c'est que vous êtes
ce n'est pas de l'hyperbole fallu mettre
la force de combat
magnifique du monde
forte forces de combat au monde vous
avez dû tellement vous battre depuis
vingt ans
beaucoup de générations
il y avait eu la génération de vos
grands parole génération dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale
génération de mon père mais aucune autre
génération n'a dû se battre
dû essuyer le sang du véhicule et
repartir par encore six mois
plusieurs reprises 40 30 40 fois en irak
et en afghanistan
et à chaque fois
la dernière fois justement
comme
dans le cockpit
à wagram en soins et il y avait à peu
près six personnes qui étaient là avec
moi et soit qu'une autre personne
c'était la première fois ni la deuxième
fois le troisième tour 4e
france 5e 6e tour
c'est la première fois que cela se
produit
en plus loin du minimum band c'est une
chose d'être
bataille rentrer à la maison et puis
d'être renvoyé sur le front ou
simplement quelque chose que j'ai dit
avant on me le reprocher mais plus
maintenant on les avait une obligation
sacré
nous avons beaucoup d'obligations
envers les personnes âgées les plus
pauvres les enfants mais une seule
obligation sacrée
équipe et ce que nous envoyons à la
guerre de prendre soin d'eux-mêmes et de
leurs femmes et lorsqu'il rentre à la
maison
un groupe incroyable d'hommes et de
femmes et je vous remercie de votre
service notant que le commandant en chef
je lui dis du fond du coeur
ce n'est pas nouveau pour moi c'est pas
mon fils est resté un homme en irak six
mois ou que ce volume on aurait gagné
des médailles nous pour moi ce qui l'a
rendu plus fier dans sa vie ça a été de
mettre l'uniforme et n' était pas obligé
loose mais lorsque son unité allait se
faire envoyer
à l'étranger il a dû avoir une dispense
il était le procureur général de l'état
il a dû démissionner pour pouvoir
accompagner ses troupes
du liban des centaines de milliers des
personnes comme mon fils comme vous tous
alors merci
merci merci merci
uniquement ce que vous faites pour aider
le peuple de l'ukraine pas uniquement ce
que vous faites pour aider l'europe pour
reprendre confiance en elles
le secrétaire d'état
12000 troupes additionnelles j'ai dit
oui nous avons cent mille troupes en
europe cela fait très longtemps que nous
n'avons pas vu ça nous sommes le
principe organisateur pour le reste du
monde
comme je l'aï dit nous avons envoyé les
meilleurs
les meilleurs disponibles des états unis
les femmes et les âmes moi je suis venu
pour une raison très simple pour dire
merci merci merci merci ou en service
merci de ce que vous êtes et merci de ce
que vous faites
cela mon grand père disait à chaque fois
que j'ai quitté chez lui
garde la foi
ma grand mère
lise et non il faut l'étendre enfin que
vous partagez cette fois merci merci
massivement qui puisse dieu vous bénisse
et vous garde que dieu protège nos
troupes merci merci
[Applaudissements]